we're happy to make it just as long as
the person ordering it understands that
it might take a little longer I'm pretty
on board with it with the drink trend
not only something cool and fun but it's
something that we as employees get there
were the occasional weird frappuccinos
that would be requested that weren't on
the menu and we're several that came out
anything from the stores Frappuccino
Hibiscus refresher the Captain Crunch
Frappuccino we also have black berries
and cream Barbra Jean oh and discoveries
and Group F you know a lot of the drink
trends we had were gravity knows when we
released the s'mores Frappuccino that
one had a lot of steps to it we had new
syrups that we had to incorporate we had
to make new whipped creams to use on the
drinks we get trains then we have to
make about five hundred of them in the
next few days because people are
ordering them the internet trends
weren't as widespread so someone would
come and order it I kind of had a vague
idea what it was this young woman came
in and wanted a I think was called a
gummy bear or a Jolly Rancher
Frappuccino I had no idea what that
drink was ones that are in these
beautiful aesthetic Instagram pictures
are ones that have been specifically
made for that I would ask the barista
that made them that drink for the recipe
definitely of course tip your baristas
especially since they're making like a
thousand drinks I would say research
what's in it see what's in it see if you
even like what's in it
Starbucks is really inventive so I have
no idea what the next drink trend is
gonna be I'm hoping that the next one is
like a rainbow Frappuccino that's like a
layered rainbow very forever Chino
probably something mapley and
maybe it has leaf on it this is kind of
what I want do you have anything else to
say go bar restarts
[Music]
Wow